figure out those codex they're gonna
have to figure eight yeah they're gonna
get drivers to make all this stuff work
and they're gonna miss a lot of it yeah
all the info is literally ones and
zeroes and has to be decoded and and put
back together again and some important
stuff if it's on a drive somewhere it
could just get nuked yeah it's gone and
then gone forever all the things that
people figured out gone don't you wish
that would happen itself I'm so cynical
man my really lately more so III think
over the course of the past few years
I've just gotten more cynical and I
think social media had a big effect on
me
well you engage too much yes I did I'm
off social media now I have been for
maybe months at least you know I did a
personal choice well the Twitter kicked
me off quite a few times just dumb [ __ ]
- it wasn't even it wasn't even that bad
like the last one it was I was defending
Jimmy Norton some girl was on just
bashing Jimmy and and I was like look at
you I go I don't even know what you are
first of all you're either a masculine
girl or a feminine guy and your hair
looks like it was dyed with period blood
is guys and bow that God they [ __ ]
permanently suspended me well that was
the bat was it loads here even lives
like you can't make fun of that you
can't make fun of somebody and works if
there's sexuality and I kind of call
them a a femme or a butch whatever it
was ever
whichever case whichever's case and to
this day I still don't know actually but
so I get kicked off a lot I have a
Twitter account now but I have not told
anybody what the name is or because I
just use it for research for the show
right because Twitter gets the news
before the news yeah like that's where
everything breaks now on Twitter you
know what's interesting to me louis
farrakhan still on twitter it's it's
amazing you ever read some of the [ __ ]
he says it's evil Jews crazy
anti-semitic unn
okay yeah unbelievable and for whatever
reason they're scared to kick him off
yeah they won't kick him off I guess
Laura Loomer is a Jewish kind of
independent reporter girl and nutcase /
nutcase whatever yeah yeah whatever you
want to yourself she changed herself to
Twitter yesterday hilarious I just
watched it on periscope as it was going
on and she's got a bullhorn and she's
just yelling at Twitter as well you lose
me you got a bullhorn
you know it's funny it's kind of
left-wing tactics she was using yeah cuz
conservatives the right Republicans
whatever you want to call it are pretty
mellow when it comes to they don't
demonstrate really they like to just get
in there and do their [ __ ] whatever it
is but liberals really like getting out
there and marching and yelling and bull
horns and stuff like that so it was
weird like to see that on the other end
yeah but she she just screaming and I
guess I guess they unhooked her and and
arrested her so they kick her off at
Twitter for they kicked her off for
talking about Islam and talking about
how Twitter was celebrating Women's Day
whatever whatever that was on a certain
day by focusing like the picture was one
of those Islamic women that got elected
to office up in was at Minnesota or
somewhere so she said how hypocritical
that was because you know Islam is for
female genital mutilation and against
women's rights and they kill gay people
and and that's all she posted and she
got kicked off for the hate speech
against Islam and and then her argument
was bluest Farrakhan is saying you know
I'm not an anti-semite I'm an anti
termite equating Jews with insects which
is yeah pretty 1930s Germany kind of a
thing so I you know while her heart was
in the right place I guess did come off
a little wacky she also had a star David
a yellow star David on her or shirt as
she was chained to Twitter people got
upset with that there she has
I just thought to tell you the truth I
thought it was a good strategic move
because you're gonna buy time with that
cuz the police do not want that optic of
a uniformed guy kind of pulling a girl
off they're wearing a star David think
it just a picture looks bad so she might
have bought her some time but I don't
know if that was her motive she planned
it out well she did apparently it was
the number one trending topic on Twitter
which is odd that you know she gets
kicked off and ends up being the number
one trending topic what's really odd is
this is wild man afford it may have
perjured himself right Mueller's going
after Trump's deeper ties Coen is now
saying that Trump was in cahoots with
Putin who's gonna give him the 50
million dollar penthouse tower in Moscow
yeah yeah you know all that it sounds
ridiculous because I got like I said I
got kicked off and I'm a little bummed
about it but it's why because it's odd
it's not just a private company anymore
that can do what they want I'm not for
government regulation so I don't know
how you fix this but Twitter is now a
thing where the Presidents on it world
leaders are discussing things on it
Emergency Management FEMA and and the
weather services they put out alerts in
case of danger or some kind of event
that's going to happen and because of
your political ideology or calling a
girl period blood hair you're not privy
to alerts and safety information that
well it's